물리학, 화학, 최적화, 머신러닝 등 여러 분야에서 나타나는 개념이에요. 그리고 서로 다르지만
동등한 방법으로 표현할 수 있어요. 행렬 ρ가 양의 반정치라는 걸 표현하는 한 가지 방법은, 어떤 행렬 M이 존재해서
ρ가 M†M과 같다고 말하는 거예요. 그리고 M 자체가 정방 행렬이어야 하는지 여부는 사실 중요하지 않아요.
그 제약을 없애도 마찬가지예요. 행렬 ρ가 양의 반정치라는 것을 표현하는 또 다른 방법은
ρ가 에르미트 행렬, 즉 켤레 전치와 같다고 말하는 거예요. 그리고 모든
고유값이 음이 아닌 실수여야 해요. 일반적으로 에르미트 행렬은
실수 고유값만 가질 수 있지만, 음수일 수도 있어요. 하지만 고유값이 음수가 될 수 없다는 조건을 추가하면
양의 반정치 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 그런데 어떤 행렬이 양의 반정치인지 알고 싶다면
이 특성으로 판단할 수 있어요. 행렬이 에르미트인지 확인하는 건 꽤 쉬워요.
그냥 눈으로 봐도 알 수 있어요. 고유값을 계산하는 건 더 어렵지만,
컴퓨터로 하면 어렵지 않아요. 매우 효율적인 알고리즘이 있거든요.
마지막으로 언급할 특성화는, 다른 것들도 있지만, ρ의 행과 열의 수와 같은 수의 원소를 가진 모든 열벡터 s에 대해
화면에 나타난 부등식이 성립한다는 거예요. 말로 표현하면, s†ρs는 음이 아닌 실수여야 해요.
이 특성화들이 모두 동등하다는 건 얼핏 보면 명확하지 않지만, 실제로 그렇거든요. 그리고 명시적으로 말씀드리면,
행렬 ρ가 양의 반정치임을 나타내는 데 흔히 사용하는 표기법은 ρ가 0보다 크거나 같다는 형태인데요.
이건 단순한 줄임 표기이고, ρ가 글자 그대로 0보다 크거나 같다는 뜻은 아니에요.
ρ는 행렬이니까 그게 말이 안 되겠죠. 그리고 ρ의 각 원소가 0보다 크거나 같다는 뜻도 아니에요.
특히, 원소가 모두 음이 아닌 것은 아닌 양의 반정치 행렬도 있고,
원소가 모두 음이 아니지만 양의 반정치가 아닌 행렬도 있어요.
이 표기법의 배경은, 양의 반정치 행렬이 음이 아닌 실수의 행렬 유사체 같다는 생각에서 나온 거예요.
하지만 이건 그냥 표기일 뿐이고, 그 의미는 정확히 이미 논의한 것이에요.
이제 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 먼저 양의 반정치 행렬의 예시부터 시작할게요.
사실 양의 반정치 행렬의 예시를 무작위로 생성하는 건 꽤 쉬워요.
임의의 행렬 M을 선택한 다음 M†M을 계산하기만 하면 돼요.
예를 들어, 특별히 특별한 게 없는 행렬 M이 여기 있어요. 실제로
이 행렬은 원소의 실수 부분과 허수 부분을 -9와 9 사이의 정수로 독립적으로 선택해서 무작위로 생성한 거예요.
그래서 여기에 보이는 패턴이나 구조는 순전히 우연이에요. M의
켤레 전치를 M에 곱하면 바로 이 행렬을 얻게 되는데, 따라서 양의
반정치예요. 물론 무작위 예시에서 얻을 수 있는 통찰에는 한계가 있지만, 더 일반적으로
양의 반정치 행렬에서 공통적으로 나타나는 특징들을 보여줘요. 특히,
왼쪽 위에서 오른쪽 아래로 이어지는 선을 따라 있는 대각 원소들이 모두 음이 아닌 실수라는 걸 알 수 있어요.
그리고 대각이 아닌 원소들은 해당하는 대각 원소, 즉 같은 행과 같은 열에 있는 원소에 비해
그다지 크지 않아요. 어떤 비대각 원소를 보든 마찬가지예요.
하지만 이게 전부가 아니에요. 양의 반정치라는 건 행렬 전체의 특성이지
개별 원소에 대한 조건이 아니라는 걸 인식하는 게 중요해요. 이게 양의 반정치 행렬의 예시이고,
비슷한 방법으로 다른 예시들을 아주 쉽게 만들 수 있어요.
이제 양의 반정치 조건 외에 트레이스도 1인 밀도 행렬의 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요.
여기 2×2 밀도 행렬의 몇 가지 예시가 있어요. 네 경우 모두 트레이스가 1이에요.
그리고 이것들이 에르미트 행렬임도 알 수 있어요. 따라서 이전의 두 번째 양의 반정치 특성화를 사용하면,
남은 것은 고유값이 모두 음이 아닌지 확인하는 거예요.
원하시면 직접 확인해 보셔도 좋아요. 2×2 행렬의 경우 손으로 고유값을 계산하는 게 그렇게 어렵지 않아요.
하지만 컴퓨터에 물어봐도 돼요. 예를 들어 Python의 선형 대수
패키지에서 eigvalsh 함수를 사용할 수 있어요. 그리고 0이 아닌 임의의
양의 반정치 행렬을 트레이스로 나눠서 밀도 행렬을 얻을 수도 있어요. 예를 들어, 조금 전에 본 예시를
트레이스로 나누면 이런 밀도 행렬을 얻어요. 이렇게 트레이스로 나누면
항상 양의 반정치 특성이 보존되고, 트레이스가 선형 함수라는 사실 덕분에
트레이스가 1인 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 이건 작은 예시 모음이고, 수업이 진행되면서 더 많은 것들을 보게 될 거예요.
다음으로 밀도 행렬의 해석이나 직관적인 의미에 대해
잠깐 이야기할게요. 먼저 인정해야 할 건,
시스템의 상태를 벡터가 아닌 행렬로 표현한다는 게 조금 낯설게 느껴질 수도 있다는 거예요.
이와 대조적으로, 양자 정보의 단순화된 공식화에서는 상태를 나타내는 데 벡터를 사용하고,
행렬, 특히 유니터리 행렬은 동작이나 연산을 나타내요. 이건 수학이 작동하는 방식이고,
행렬을 선형 매핑으로 설명하는 것으로 항상 생각할 수 있지만, 특정 밀도 행렬과 관련된
선형 매핑에 직접적인 직관적 의미를 부여하지는 않아요. 그렇긴 해도,
밀도 행렬이 실제로 행렬이라는 사실은 그것들의 중요한 측면으로 밝혀지며, 앞으로 계속
살펴볼 거예요. 지금 당장 한 가지 예시만 간단히 언급하면, 주어진 밀도 행렬의 고유값은
매우 중요한데, 왜냐하면 그 밀도 행렬이 설명하는 상태에 내재된 무작위성이나 불확실성의 정도를
나타내기 때문이에요. 직관적인 수준에서 밀도 행렬을 생각하는 또 다른 방법은
이 행렬들의 원소에 초점을 맞추는 거예요. 밀도 행렬의 행과 열이
우리가 이야기하는 시스템의 고전적 상태와 대응되어 있다는 걸 기억해 주세요. 따라서 각 원소에는 하나의